vous êtes fait
pour obéir
à la fin
ce sera chacun pour soi
on fait quoi
on se tient prêt
il y avait un projet
le projet de réunir
un groupe de personnes hors du commun
à notre disposition
pour livrer les batailles
on ne pourrait gagner
messieurs
jusqu'où tu vous prêt à l'est
ne le prends pas mal mais je fait
cavalier seul joue les héros avec ton
art mûr mais sans lt quoi ingénié
milliardaire et playboy philanthrope
si on ne peut pas protéger la terre
je peux vous assurer qu'on a fait en
charge
soto valeur aux travaux souffrance
équivalent et j'adore votre façon de
perdre le contrôle on est devenu un
monstre vert grappillant
merci